so this is your
second book but it's your first
fictional book correct yes
yes
so how did you find writing fiction
compared to writing your first book
oh wow yeah two different two different
books yeah so
uh my first book uh bless mode is a
devotional book
and so that is a a book that you can get
into every day uh it gets people ready
for their day um letting them know
they're beautifully and wonderfully made
by god
uh and so i really wrote that book to uh
give people breakthrough in their life
because people are dealing with a lot of
stress and i just wanted to have them
just let go of that every day and then
with uh prank day uh you can also let go
uh of some stress and go on an adventure
uh
in this book i love
uh movies like back to the future and
never in the story and my science
project and uh you know stories that
take you on a wild ride and i wanted to
do something fun
uh with an adventure uh fiction novel
and i started started off with an idea
where it was what if all your pranks
came true the next day and
what if one of those pranks that you did
could change your life completely if you
don't figure out why these pranks are
coming true uh so and i just took it on
a real fun journey awesome story to uh
just write and to now see the characters
come alive on this book cover and
through the illustrations uh and
everybody's reading these uh uh awesome
story that uh that i've uh put together
uh so much fun
to
see uh where did you get the inspiration
like were you a prankster yourself as a
kid
yeah um also i did some pranks i did a
prank one of my notorious ones was uh i
put glue uh in my friend's seat uh in
class and it was crazy glue so when
everybody got up to leave he couldn't
obviously uh he was stuck to the chair
uh i got a big trouble for that one so i
would advise the kids not to do that one
uh but he's okay so i always tell people
like if you're doing a prank make sure
everybody laughs together um i want it
so he thought it was funny uh he they
did cut him loose from the chair
so he thought it was funny that's
amazing um do you see yourself writing
more fiction going forward
definitely you know i've also write uh
movie scripts as well and so uh in
sketches and stuff like that so uh this
is right up the alley you know what i
mean um i feel
i've been in uh kid entertainment for
years and so i really got a sense of
like the comedy the zany comedy so uh
definitely i want to do more gonna
continue to do more and i don't want to
give it away but uh at the end of prank
day uh i leave it a little bit open for
uh a sequel and i wanted to do that so
i'm gonna see how people respond to it
yeah i noticed i noticed
um so i love that you dedicated uh your
book to your two youngest um i know
they're still very young obviously but
like did you know did you get a chance
to read this book to them is this
something that you hope they get to read
on their own someday
oh definitely uh my youngest uh
daughter uh she actually got to see the
cover um she approved it for me
uh when my illustrator santi sent over
the final cover of the look of it i said
hey check this out and she was like oh
who are those characters that's fun and
i'm like oh yep that's good and i'm like
so this is daddy's book so if you think
this is a good coverage like yeah and uh
i've read to both of the kids the book
not the full book because they're not
you know 8 and 12 yet this is for tweens
but
i encourage parents that they can also
read prank day uh to their toddlers by
reading it chapter by chapter and just
put some voices to it uh and it is still
work and so i have been doing that and
they're enjoying it
yeah
uh what do you love most about being a
dad
what i love most about being a dad oh
man it's so much fun
uh just them
getting to see me and how i uh navigate
through certain things and to see them
how they navigate
through certain things and they're
finding the uh you know the joy in
things and also them seeing me
um
you know being a dad and just loving
them
and not responding in emotions and just
really taking my time to say hey let's
pray on this let's uh let's have some
fun together uh what do you enjoy and i
love seeing what they enjoy what they
gravitate towards uh because it's so
beautiful because each one of my
children are different and i love that
and uh yeah i just i love i love being a
dad and watching their journey because
everybody's journey is different and i
love watching theirs as well and i'm
happy to be a part of it and i'm happy
that god chose me to be their father you
know
that's beautiful you can really tell how
much you love your kids um and it's so
fun that you have now this thing that
you can share with another thing
obviously you have like you said a
plethora of work i mean
um you know if you haven't gone in
to acting do you feel like being an
author is something you would have
pursued sooner or
a great later um
you know what now i'm thinking about it
i think i probably would have yeah been
an author sooner uh the only reason i
say that is because uh my dad um as a
retired psychologist and my mom is a
retired teacher but something that they
did all the time
is that they had me read books and so
they would hand me a book and say hey
come back after you're done with it then
i want you to actually do a book report
in front of us you know so i had to do
like a book report and talk about the
book and uh every time i would enjoy
doing this because i would you know
literally put on a a show for them and
do the characters of the book i read
which was super awesome and i really
loved the characters and the story arcs
uh within every book so yeah i'm sure i
would have been an author either either
that or
some or some type of storyteller because
i love comic books as well so
definitely